Mình có dưới làm thành phụ cảm au
Mình sẽ có tưởng nền của bác hòa để chấp hơn
Chấp hơn nền của bác hòa mục tiền bây bè, các bạn thấy dưới làm thành phố
Một con trên chấp hơn, bây bè, hoặc nơi, cái đoạn của bà, bún đánh xe
Cám phép, của gí tất, thì hãy dùng khi bà bú xe sớm hoàn hiểu tối
Rất rất là đẹp sinh đạo em, cảm thấy là tự thè,
khi mà ở dưới lọc thành phố không mọt với dưới chim,
có như loa chim như thế này.
Tại vì mất quá mình phải đại chim nên đi để tư chú bà
từ những chạm lại như thế này, mình mới giả.
Đây là tư chương trường các thúc hấp,
nhưng cũng có thể đánh dụ,
là khi người đấy,
tình thật, cái vình chiến, để phục dưới cho bà khóng,
các đếm đấu, thì mọi là một chứ để tự cho thật.
Học thân tữ lật là không chả nó bà như được,
nhưng thì mà chúng ta thật và mình hỗ sông thức khăn
Mình nhỏ, sau khi các địa kinh trong gì bằng đánh, nhưng mà gì mà châu.